MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Well, we got a huge
audience today.
Google Food and
Talks at Google is
proud to present Hans
Roeckenwagner, Chef
LA for a long time, 3
Square Bistro and then also
Roeckenwagner Bakery
and Cafe fame.
So he's going be demoing
a couple recipes.
For those of you who
received cookbooks,
there's a card in there.
So if you'd like to
just fill it out,
send it to the emailing list.
They'll happily send
you the recipes.
And then also,
afterwards, there's
also an opportunity
to sign up for that.
So without further ado,
Chef Hans Roeckenwagner.
[APPLAUSE]
HANS ROECKENWAGNER: It's
just not morning anymore.
Hello, everyone.
This the first time I've done
a demo with so many computers.
I guess there's a
first for everything,
and today is the first for that.
Anyway, my name's Hans
Roeckenwagner, as Jeff said.
And believe it or
not, I am going
to be celebrating my
30 year anniversary
of being in the food
business in Los Angeles.
That's a dinosaur
in our industry, OK?
[APPLAUSE]
I feel like Jurassic
Park sometimes.
30 years.
Imagine that.
1985, I opened my
first restaurant
literally down the street right
here where Joe's is right now.
Everyone know where Joe's is?
That was my restaurant.
I built that restaurant
actually with my bare hands.
I had $70,000.
That's all I had, which I
borrowed from my family.
And my wife and I opened
our first restaurant.
We had nine tables.
I think we had 36 seats.
And that was the dream for us,
24 years old, young and stupid.
But I think that's
actually the only way
to do it, to be honest.
Because this industry
can eat you alive.
So what I'd like
to do today, I'm
going to show a couple of
recipes from my first book.
I have two cookbooks,
and one which you're
holding your hand, some of you.
And the other one is
from the first cookbook.
And as Jeff said,
send us your email
and we'll email you the recipe.
What I'd like to do, I'd
like to do stuff as I talk.
I think you're here more
to hear me talk than to do.
And please ask me questions,
because that gives me
an idea of what you want to know
and what you're interested in.
Everyone is interested
in food now, right?
I mean, for sure you are.
You're here.
But think even those
who are not here,
everyone's interested in food.
What is that?
What gets us together
like that about food?
It's not just sustenance.
And that's actually what
drew me so the restaurant
business a little bit.
Maybe I won't even
go to my recipes.
There's something about food
that unites us and brings
us together.
And one of the most
satisfying things for me
is to walk into, hopefully, my
restaurant, a busy restaurant,
and see people
enjoying themselves.
Not just in the
food-- the ambience,
the service, getting
together and just having fun.
Actually, one of the things,
having been in this industry
for so long and having had
a restaurant for so long,
I was in Los Angeles during
a very difficult time when
we had the fires,
we had the riots,
we had the earthquakes in
a very short succession.
Some of you may remember
that, others not.
But there was a time when
LA felt really disconnected,
and down, and out.
And everyone counted us out.
And I felt I needed
to do something
to get people together.
Because we grow up in
this car culture and we
barely look at each other.
And now we're on our computers,
and that's good for you,
but not so good for us.
But I felt we needed
to do something
to create community again.
And there was this thing in
Germany that we used to do.
It's called stammtisch.
And literally it's--
Stammtisch has two meanings.
One, the four of us could
get together and say, OK,
every third Wednesday
of the month,
we're going to get together.
We're going to sit
around this big table.
We're going to have a drink,
and we're going to eat,
and we're going
to talk politics,
whatever we feel like doing.
And that's what's
called a stammtisch.
And the other thing
about stammtisch
is actually the table itself.
It used to be a very gnarly,
big, wooden table that sat,
and it was reserved for
regulars, for regulars only.
So if you came as a foreigner
or someone that doesn't frequent
that restaurant, and you
would sit at that table,
you'd literally get
kicked out because it
was reserved for the regulars.
So I felt I needed to
do something like that.
And I started stammtisch
in '90-- I think '93?
And I said, OK, I sent out
some emails to some friends.
And I said every Tuesday--
it was then Tuesday--
every Tuesday,
let's get together.
Just come have a bite.
Have a drink.
And something big
grew out of that.
Over the next 10 years, we
built this into this big thing
where people always
knew every Tuesday night
I know where I'm going to be.
I'm going to be
at Roeckenwagner.
That was then my prized
possession restaurant
on Main Street here
at the Edgemar.
Everyone knows the
Edgemar Complex?
So in the back,
there's a restaurant.
It's still there now.
I sold it actually in 2006.
And we did stammtisch.
And people knew
exactly where to be.
And I'm really proud
of having done that.
A lot of friendships
have formed.
A lot of things
have happened there.
And we still do it now.
Every Wednesday night at
3 Square, I'm there air.
I'm at 3 Square, and
I'm hosting the table.
Anyone who wants to join, meet
some new people, have a beer,
have a laugh, come on down.
All right.
I should really get cooking.
If not, I'm going to-- so
we're going to do today, we're
going to do kadaifi-wrapped
shrimp on a eggplant caviar,
melanzane with
marinated tomatoes.
And what I want
to focus on today
a little bit is the
eggplant caviar.
Everything else is
going to be pretty
simple and straightforward.
Eggplant, being a
native of Germany,
we didn't have eggplant.
I mean, we had it,
but it was brought in.
But we all look
at this vegetable
sometimes, what are we
going to do with it?
Right?
It's a little
intimidating, right?
And actually
eggplant is a fruit.
It's a berry.
It has seeds, and the seeds, at
times, can make it a little bit
bitter.
So as we're doing it,
I'm going to show you.
So let me start.
These are the Ichiban eggplants,
the long, slender ones.
This is what we have right now.
They're in season all year long,
but to be honest, generally
I prefer the big big, golden
eggs, the black bells,
for this particular dish.
What I've done
here ahead of time
is I charred some
of these eggplants
and I got them ready for you.
And I mean charred.
I'm not messing
around with this, OK?
So you can do this over a grill,
or you can do it over a burner
just like this.
You put them cut side
down and don't touch them.
Just leave them there.
In about three,
four, five minutes,
we're going to check them
out, and I want them literally
charred like this, OK?
So this is your chance
to really burn it.
All right.
So I'm going to
keep this going just
to show you roughly
how long it takes
and how charred I want it.
Now, these, when you're done
with this, you can see here.
I'm going to show you.
We're going to get rid of
some, obviously, as much as
possible of this black,
charred substance,
and also some of the seeds.
You don't want to take
out all the seeds.
But see how nicely this
is just being scraped off?
OK.
And then, literally.
If you start at the stem,
you can scrape this right out
of the shell.
OK.
So if you have a few pieces
of the char in there,
I like that actually because
it gives a smoky flavor.
I like smoky flavor.
I like sausages.
I like anything smoked.
But still, you can always
add a little more at the end.
Let me try to do a couple more.
We'll add it.
Let's check this out here.
So this is not
enough yet, clearly.
Because there's two
things we're doing here.
We're charring it to
get some of the flavor,
and also we're cooking it.
We're going to cook it in
the shell, in the skin.
So we want to really char it
very well on the cut side,
and then we're going to
turn it around, and give it
more heat from the bottom and
actually cook it in its skin.
So any questions so far?
No?
I'm that good?
Come on.
Ask me something.
Maybe you see it better
on this one actually.
It comes out even better.
It could've been maybe cooked
just a little bit more.
It'll be nice and soft.
OK.
I'm going to put that aside.
So let me talk about
my bakery a little bit.
Are some of you are
familiar with my bakery?
Yes?
I don't see enough hands.
OK.
Excellent.
That is actually my
big business now.
In 1992, 1991, when I sold the
restaurant on Abbot Kinney,
I moved down to Main Street.
And I felt, you know what?
I really can't find the
bread that I want for my food
and for my sandwiches.
And I brought a master
baker from Germany
and started a bakery as
part of the restaurant.
And this bakery, that
was part of my kitchen,
started to produce
some really good stuff.
One of them, which
you're eating right now,
that's something we've
become known for-- pretzels.
And within a year or
so after we opened,
there was a little
coffee shop that
opened right in front of us.
And that was Peet's Coffee.
And one day, unbeknownst
to me, this woman walks in.
And I kid you not, her
name was Janet Coffee.
I'm not making this up.
Janet Coffee walks in
the door and says, hi.
I'm Janet Coffee.
I work for Peet's Coffee.
We'd like to carry
your pastries.
We're like, OK.
Well, that's easy.
You're right up front.
We'll bake it in the back.
We'll bring it to the front.
No problem.
Yeah, but we have
five other locations.
So all of a sudden, I had to get
a truck, I had to get a driver.
And that's how our bakery
started, literally-- out
of the back of our kitchen.
So in the daytime,
it was a restaurant.
In the nighttime,
it was a bakery.
It was a perfect
use of the space
and, economically,
obviously very good.
And that's just about right.
Now, you'd never think
of doing this, right?
So we started delivering
Peet's Coffee.
And little by little, we
got another account here,
another account there.
And all of a sudden, I
found myself, you know,
this bakery is really
something I should
be taking more seriously.
And then a few years later,
we bought this little space
on Washington Boulevard
near Beethoven,
which now is the little
cafe of ours where
we do breakfast and lunch.
If you haven't been
there, go by there.
It's a really charming
little neighborhood
spot-- super friendly, great
coffee, great pastries.
So we moved our
production there,
because we really had outgrown.
One thing I learned, actually,
is flour and oil don't mix.
So in a restaurant
kitchen environment,
you have a lot of oil--
the friars, the sauteing,
all this stuff going on.
Even though you
have hoods, there's
always some of it in the air.
So the bakers would
come in at night
and the flour is everywhere.
Bakers, I mean, there's
flour everywhere, OK?
It's kind of like drywall dust.
It gets everywhere.
So we figured out,
you know what?
We really need to take
this somewhere else.
So we moved into this-- OK.
So it depends on how big
the eggplants are, right?
And the moisture of
the eggplant also.
I'm just about done
with the charring.
If I feel that maybe
they're cooked enough
and all I need to do is
feel them out a little bit,
I would then-- is
there plastic wrap?
Jeff, is there plastic wrap?
Well, I'll tell you.
I would put it in a
bowl or in a container.
Right?
Wrap it in plastic
and just let it sit.
And like that, you're
cooking it a little bit more
and a little bit
longer, and you're also
steaming it up a little bit.
The skin is easier to remove.
You may have seen it on a
couple of the eggplants where
it was very easy.
So that's one little tip.
Where was I?
Yes?
Ah, you can.
I haven't done it.
AUDIENCE: I always set off mine.
HANS ROECKENWAGNER: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: I always set off
my smoke alarm [INAUDIBLE].
HANS ROECKENWAGNER:
Oh, the smoke alarm?
Well, the smoke alarm
comes from the smoke,
not whether it's a
broiler or the stove top.
You know these things?
I don't know.
They're $15, $20.
It's so easy.
If you're in an environment
that's very sensitive,
and now more and
more of you are.
You may want to
take one of these
and put it out on the
balcony and do it.
And I'm sure there's
other uses you
can-- these come in really
handy, these little burners.
But you can do it
on the broiler.
Whether or not that's going
to help your smoke alarm,
I don't know.
All right.
So we got our eggplant.
And once you have the
eggplant, obviously you
need more than this.
OK.
What you want to do is, you
want to get a cheesecloth,
a food grade cheesecloth.
Well, they're all food
grade, more or less.
And you put out the cheesecloth.
You put it in the center.
You pull up the ends,
and you literally
let it hang like a little bag
in the refrigerator overnight.
And we do that actually in
commercial cooking a lot
because some things
just need time to drain.
You could try to squeeze
it out, but you're
going to squeeze out a
lot of the good also,
a lot of the meat.
Whereas, you give it time,
it just does it by itself.
Gravity works, I can tell you.
And it's just much easier.
For instance, what we do also--
have you ever had tomato water?
You can do tomato
water like that
also, where you literally
take the tomatoes.
You put it in the blender,
and you blend it really well.
And you lie it in a bowl
with the cheesecloth,
and you put the tomatoes in.
Pull up the ends and hang
it over another bowl.
And the next day, you
have clear tomato water,
which is delicious.
And you can use it as a
soup, just a little bit
of snipped chives.
It's delicious.
Tomato water.
We used to do that a lot too.
So back to the eggplant.
All right.
We have the eggplant.
I'm going to just
chop this by hand.
I don't need the
Robot Coupe for that.
And to be honest, so
sometimes it depends.
When you have eggplant caviar,
sometimes it's more chunky.
Sometimes, it's more pureed.
The one that you're
going to be tasting
has been pureed because
we made so much.
But now these days,
I feel the less I
process my food, the better.
Because I really want
the essence of the food.
I'm kind of old school, OK?
As you can tell, no
tats, no earrings, no--
I dare you to find any
other chefs like that,
unless they're 60 years old.
So again, now these days
when I go to restaurants,
and I go out a lot.
I go to New York a lot.
My wife works in New York.
And we go out a
lot, and very often,
at the end of the meal--
not even at the end.
The next day, I say to my wife,
so what did we eat last night?
And if I can remember
a few things,
and they're vividly in
my palate, in my brain,
then I know I had a good meal.
If I don't remember what I had?
Well, what did we have?
Oh yeah.
We had chicken.
What chicken?
Well, you know, I don't know.
That's not good enough for me.
Right?
And the other thing is
I want to taste what I'm
being told I'm going to have.
I don't want 50,000 ingredients
I can't tell one of them,
you know?
So that's why I
actually like this.
This is a Mediterranean dish.
Every doctor I've
ever had told me
you should be on the
Mediterranean diet.
OK, well, we'll do that today.
So the reason I come to that
is because this eggplant,
I can put it in the food
processor, which I prepped,
but I don't have it now.
But actually, I want to show you
that we can just do it by hand,
not overprocessed, still have
a little bit of texture, right?
And get the essence
of the eggplant.
OK.
A little bit more shallots.
A little bit of garlic.
A little bit of yogurt.
This is just to
make it smoother.
Salt, pepper.
A little bit of vinegar.
I like white vinegar here.
And then just a little
bit of olive oil.
And this is your fresh
eggplant caviar, or melanzane.
So, again, how long
did that take us?
If I hadn't talked so much, it
would be done in five minutes,
right?
OK.
Actually, a couple of things
that I can put in here--
sometimes I do.
Sometimes I don't.
And that's what
cooking is about also.
Cooking is about the moment.
Where is it?
Right here.
I have some dill, fresh dill.
I just put in a little
dill, just to give it
a little bit more, just another
dimension, a little added
flavor.
It doesn't distract
from for my eggplant
but will only make it
better and enhance it.
So that's really
it for my eggplant.
Pretty straightforward, right?
And this, to be honest, you
can put on a piece of fish,
you can put on a piece of
meat, you can eat with chips,
you can eat it on a sandwich.
This is one of those
building blocks
that we're always talking about
in the kitchen, a building
block that really
builds your dish.
It can be the dish
itself, or it can enhance
anything you put it with.
Goes good with seafood.
Goes good with chicken.
I think it goes even
good with steak.
Kadaifi is not only one
of those-- it's actually
a Middle Eastern thing.
And kadaifi is shredded filo.
Are you guys familiar
with filo dough?
Filo is super, super
thin dough that we
tried to make at one point, and
later on, I went to the factory
to see how they make
it professionally.
The guy said why are
you making it yourself?
It's really a lot of work.
A little bit similar to a
strudel dough, actually.
So it almost looks
like angel hair, right?
And it's a little
bit hard to find.
You want to probably go to
a Middle Eastern store that
specializes in
ingredients like this.
OK.
We have our shrimp.
We have some shrimp here.
I have a mess.
I actually never work in
a mess, but right now-- I
have the shrimp.
I'm going to marinate
these just a little bit.
I'm going to add some basil,
salt, pepper, olive oil.
You may have noticed that
all the things that I do I
try to impart flavor
from the beginning.
And sometimes, that may
be very basic ingredients,
and sometimes that may be more
complex ingredients like spices
and things like that.
OK, a little bit of basil,
a little bit of olive oil,
salt, pepper.
And you just want to
marinate these a little bit,
maybe a half an
hour before, just
to impart some basic flavor.
You know one thing we forgot
on the eggplant caviar?
Lemon juice.
Also very good.
Sometimes, you want to use
lemon juice versus vinegar,
but you need a
little bit of acid,
and I'd like to get into that.
So now should we put them in?
Or what do you think?
Now we're going to take
this kadaifi, right?
We'll lay it out, and then
we wrap our shrimp in it.
That's it.
So in the recipe from
my first book, actually,
we used to fry these.
Since most of you
don't have fryers,
and hopefully you don't have
a commercial kitchen at home,
let me give you a little tip.
So very often when you
talk about fried food,
there's a few reasons for
frying food-- A, it's delicious,
and B, you crisp it up, right?
You make it really
crisp, and that's
what we like in what I
think are the juxtapositions
between hot and cold, crisp
and soft, sweet and sour.
And so in this, I may put a
little olive oil on the sheet
pan, place this on the
olive oil, and just spray
it a little bit, the finer
the mist, the better.
And then I just bake it.
And you get a similar
flavor but less oil,
and you still get the crispness.
So we actually have the
ones for you guys to try.
We just put them in the oven.
The kadaifi, you've
never heard of it?
Yeah, we chefs have a
way of finding stuff.
No, I think I was actually
exposed to it by one
of my cooks very
early on, who said,
hey, chef, have you
ever tried this?
And I said, hey, bring it over.
Let's try it out.
And when I came to the States,
you have to understand,
I came here in 1980.
I feel so old been quoting dates
to you, but I kind of have to.
So when I came over
to the States in 1983,
I came from Germany.
I worked in France, and
Switzerland, and Germany.
What we had was French food,
German food, Swiss food,
which is very similar to
German food, and Italian food.
There were no Mexican
restaurants, Thai restaurants,
Chinese restaurants.
I mean, there were maybe
a few here or there,
but I was never exposed to that.
I came from a very
small, little town.
OK, later on in
my apprenticeship
and when I worked in France
and in Switzerland, but again,
there was maybe one
Chinese restaurant
in a large metropolitan
area, or one Thai restaurant.
And we weren't that exposed.
But when I came here, my wife
took me to all these places.
I said, wow, this is great.
And there was a treasure trove
of ingredients, and techniques,
and flavors that I
discovered, that I then
started to blend in with
my German food and so
became part of this
California cuisine revolution
that's really based
on local ingredients.
I know local is a
way overused word,
but I have bought produce
at that farmer's market
in Santa Monica for 30 years.
Local to me is nothing new.
I grew up on local, OK?
But what I would what
we would do then,
that generation
of cooks-- and I'm
talking Wolfgang Puck,
and Michel Richard,
and Joachim Splichal,
and Matsuhisa-- these
are somewhat my contemporaries.
They're people that did
all this at the same time I
was doing it.
And so I had, obviously, a
very strong German background.
And I would start
cooking my food
and then add a little cilantro,
and at a little soy sauce,
and add a little bit
of ginger, ingredients
that I wasn't that familiar
with but was exposed to
and started
incorporating in my food.
And that's how I
developed my style.
Because this is
a very-- now this
could be labeled as maybe a
touch of Asian, but definitely
Mediterranean, Middle Eastern.
You know, it's not-- you can't
peg it just to one thing.
So that's how my
original restaurant,
which was a very
high end restaurant
that I ran for 23 years.
23 years, I ran a
high end restaurant
that was consistently listed as
one of the top 10 restaurants.
I got the articles
to prove it to you.
But then-- wow.
Where am I?
Where do we want to go
with this conversation?
Do you want to
hear more of that?
Or do you want to hear
more of the bakery?
What are you interested in?
Nothing?
AUDIENCE: Laugenbrot.
HANS ROECKENWAGNER: I'm sorry?
HANS ROECKENWAGNER:
The Laugenbrot.
Laugenbrot.
Laugenbrot, the
gentleman over here
just referred to something that
in Germany we call laugenbrot.
Really what it means is
it's a pretzel bread.
We at the bakery obviously
do a lot with pretzels.
We make what we call
German twister pretzels.
We make pretzel rolls.
We make pretzel bagels.
We make pretzels sliders.
We make pretzel croissants.
We make pretzel chips.
We tried to do everything
with pretzels we can.
And that's our big thing.
In the meantime, we have
grown so big in our bakery
that we now supply
Peet's Coffee, all
the Peet's Coffee in
the Southern California
area, about 32 stores.
We're in all the Whole Foods,
about 33 stores and counting.
We're in all the Gelson's.
We supply about 400 to
500 accounts every day.
We have 13 trucks on the road.
We have about 125 employees
just at the bakery.
That's the big business now.
This is just fun.
No, I'm really
proud of the bakery
and what we've done
with it, you know?
And if it continues to be an
education to me every day--
every day.
Because now, all
of a sudden, you
deal with logistics and
drivers and so many things.
But it's fun.
It's just-- I'm having a blast.
But I still like to
cook, and I still
like to be part
of the restaurant.
It's just that the
bakery right now
is taking a lot more time
out of my daily schedule.
And another thing
that's taking-- I
have to brag about
this a little bit.
On Sunday, I'm going
to do a bike ride
from Los Angeles to San Diego.
And it's part of Chefs Ride.
And it's three days,
100 miles each day,
and we're raising money for
Share Our Strength for the No
Kid Hungry Program.
Since I'm in the
dude's room today,
he is a big advocate
for this as well.
And he's going to meet
us in Santa Barbara.
And we are raising bonds feed
the kids that can't afford.
One out of five kids
in the US does not
know where their next meal
is going to come from.
In my mind, that's
unconscionable.
And a bunch of chefs
have gotten together.
There's a group
on the East Coast
that just finished
their ride last night.
There's a group on the West
Coast of notable chefs.
We got together, and we said,
OK, we're going to raise funds.
Each of us pledged to
raise at least $10,000.
I was the first to raise
$10,000 on the West Coast.
And altogether we're going
to raise some $400,000.
Each dollar feeds four kids
with subsidies and everything.
So if you feel like it,
putting in a couple of dollars
here and there, every
dollar feeds four kids.
This doesn't go to me.
I'm on a bike starting
Sunday morning,
riding my bike from Santa
Barbara to San Diego.
So I'm really proud of that.
I haven't done it yet,
but I've raised the money.
[LAUGHTER]
I've raised the money,
and that's what counts.
So what else?
Tomatoes.
So these are beautiful
heirloom tomatoes.
We very often peel our tomatoes.
Because I think by
doing that-- there's
a lot of different
thoughts on this.
You're removing a
lot of the nutrients
that, generally,
for most vegetables,
are right under the skin.
But since I am as
much about flavor
as I'm about the nutrients, it
makes it a lot more flavorful.
So we have beautiful
heirloom tomatoes here.
We peeled them.
We seeded them,
and we diced them.
OK?
I've got some red ones.
A little bit of
salt. I'm not going
to put the black pepper
right here, because I
don't want it to distract
from this beautiful color.
So if I had finely
ground white pepper,
I would probably
use white pepper.
A little bit of olive oil.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HANS ROECKENWAGNER: Hot water.
Put them in a colander.
Hot water, count to
10, pull them out.
OK.
Thank you for asking.
Tomato.
Take the tomato, you make
a little cross in the top.
OK?
Then, as I said, hot, boiling
water, not salted or flavored.
Put it in there.
Pull it out after 10 seconds.
Then where you made the cross,
generally if the tomato's ripe,
you'll see that it's already
starting to peel off.
OK?
And if you notice that
you can peel it off,
then you shock them in ice
water to stop the cooking.
And then you peel your tomato.
If the skin does
not I'm off yet,
you just put them back
in until you're ready.
These peel very easily.
The cardboard tomatoes that
you buy in the supermarket,
they'll be mush before
you can peel them.
There's a few ingredients you
really don't want to skimp,
and a tomato is one of them.
Why eat a tomato if you can't
get any flavor out of it?
So olive oil and just a little
bit of-- these are my cooks.
They make it foolproof for me.
We could go through
an earthquake.
Nothing would happen.
Anyone notice yesterday?
That was earthquake weather.
I don't know about
you, I was worried.
A little bit balsamic
vinegar, not too much.
We just want it for flavoring.
Maybe a little more olive oil.
And this is where your
touch can come in.
You can add dill.
You can add basil.
You can add a little ginger.
You can add garlic.
It's up to you.
As if now by magic, the
cooked shrimp would appear,
I'd be happy.
OK, so now we have
our eggplant caviar,
which gives us this beautiful,
earthy, smoky flavor, and also
creamy and soft.
Then we have the tomatoes
with the acidity, the sweet,
and the sour, and the
coolness of the tomato.
And then we're going to have
our shrimp, firm, plump,
juicy shrimp, with
the crisp surrounding.
I mean, you can't go wrong.
So acidity.
Let's talk acidity a little bit.
In my first cookbook, I devoted
a whole chapter do that.
Because very often people at
home, they cook something.
At the end, they taste it.
And you know, it's
good, but it's just not
as good as at Hans's place.
[CHUCKLING]
So I believe that almost
anything needs a balance.
And that balance
very often comes
from adding a little bit of
acidity, whether or not that's
lemon juice, lime
juice, vinegar.
All those things just add
a little bit of-- they
open up your palate, and they
make everything else shine.
So next time you make a
salsa, obviously, lime juice.
Right?
Or you make this eggplant
caviar, a little lemon juice
or a little bit of vinegar.
Try this.
Even in sauces, very often
when we make brown sauces,
at the end, we add a
teaspoon of balsamic vinegar
or just a little bit
of cherry vinegar.
And it just opens up
the whole spectrum
of flavors to everything else.
I am almost done.
So any more questions?
God.
I don't know.
I know.
This always gets me in
trouble, but there's really
nothing left.
I hate to say it.
There was-- well, there's me
again, old timer speaking.
There was a place on
Wilshire Boulevard that was
called the Black Forest Inn.
That was actually very good.
And the guy, Norbert, a
good friend of mine, older.
He was about, I don't know, 15
years, maybe, older than me.
This guy was in the
kitchen for, I don't know,
35 years, every single day.
And then he sold the restaurant.
This is so sad.
He sold the restaurant.
He died within half a year.
It was the craziest thing.
This guy needed his kitchen.
But that was a very
good German restaurant.
At that time, this was,
again, in the mid-90s.
This almost broke
my heart, because I
remember him getting a review.
I'm not going to say
who the reviewer was,
but this was a reviewer
who had published
Spanish Catalan and
French cookbooks himself
and authored many, many
articles on that region of food.
And then he went out to
critique a German restaurant.
He gave it a really bad review.
And I felt really
bad about m you know?
I don't think he got
that kind of food.
It's so funny.
I just read an
article the other day
that we are actually more
influenced by German stuff
overall through our ancestors
than any other background,
I think.
But I think what has happened
is it's being assimilated
into American culture.
So there's a lot of
things that we now
consider American that
actually came from Germany.
I mean, one of then is the
hamburger, the hot dog.
It was a Viennese-- it was
a German hot dog that is,
including the hamburger,
one of the most
popular foods in this country.
Delicatessen, that's
a German thing.
So there's a lot of things
that we consider now American.
And that's great I
think that's all good.
White asparagus.
Thank you.
We actually just
finished the season.
So that's been actually--
I've been a big champion
of the white asparagus.
And that's one of the
things that, again, I
did very early on.
OK, I'm going to get back
to that in just a second.
So let's plate this.
Will you give me three of them?
So there's many different ways
I could plate this, right?
I'm making this up
as I go here, OK?
Like everything in life.
I love plating food.
Always have.
For a while there, my
high end restaurant
was considered to be
serving architectural food.
That was in the '80s.
That was a hot thing.
Since we eat with
our eyes as much
as we do with our stomachs,
you want to make it look nice.
This is sort of a fancy--
fancier presentation.
We could add some
dill if we wanted to.
We could have some fun and
just play around with it.
The reason we do
this sometimes is
because this shows that
it's light, actually.
And it has air.
It could almost fly away.
So that's it.
The only thing I may
add to this is just
a little bit of olive oil.
And to be honest, why are
we adding the olive oil?
For flavor.
That's why Americans
actually have had the hardest
time with olive oil.
I've cooked in Italy.
I've gone to some of the
best restaurants in Italy,
and the first thing the
chef in the kitchen takes in
is, this is my olive oil.
Everyone has a
different olive oil.
But every chef tell you,
this is my olive oil.
And they use the olive
oil completely different
than we do.
It's a flavoring agent.
Add a soup.
You make a great,
great bean soup?
You put a little olive
oil on top of it.
And you get that
creaminess, and that flavor,
and that earthiness from
that particular olive oil,
whether or not it's
acidic or it's peppery.
OK?
So olive oil,
that's how we should
use oil olive, especially
extra virgin olive oil.
Never ever, ever fry an
It's a waste of money.
OK?
You're wasting your money.
This is like gold, and that's
how you have to treat it.
You drizzle it a little bit
on the end, on your salad,
on your grilled steak,
on your grilled fish.
And it opens up, again,
that extra level of flavors.
So back to asparagus.
why are we cutting?
Why are we cutting?
Oh, we don't have enough, OK?
That's the price of popularity.
[CHUCKLING]
White asparagus.
So I grew up in an area where
we grow white asparagus.
And when I came here, I was
exposed to, believe it or not,
I had seen green
asparagus in Germany,
but it wasn't as common
as the white asparagus.
And the white asparagus
is a delicacy.
Not that green is not, but
the white asparagus never
gets exposed to the sunlight.
And so it gets
harvested very early
in the morning 4, or 5
o'clock, while it's still
not full sunshine.
And, literally, there
are these mounds of dirt.
So you have to imagine
this row of dirt.
And the asparagus kind
of grows out on the side.
And what they do is
when they harvest it,
they can see where the topsoil
breaks, where it cracks.
And they can tell that's
where an asparagus is.
Then they had these
little shovels, they
and literally cut this asparagus
deep down, about this long,
out of the ground.
So each stock is hand harvested.
It's white.
It's about this thick,
thicker than a thumb,
and it needs to be peeled.
But when it's made
right, it's about one
of the best things
you'll ever have.
And it's pure, and you
can tell the terroire,
the soil that it comes out,
you can tell the minerals.
And, generally,
when we make it, we
make it as unchanged
as possible.
We just add-- we
boil it in water
with a little salt, a
little lemon juice--
acidity-- and a little
bit butter at the top.
Because then as you pull
it out of the water,
it coats it with
butter a little bit.
It's so good.
So when I came here, there was
no white asparagus here, right?
I said, oh, I gotta change this.
And I started-- this was in '87.
I started actually importing
my own white asparagus
from Germany.
I had to get an
agricultural permit.
importing license.
I had to do all kinds of stuff
to bring in white asparagus.
And the first three years
I did it, I lost money.
But I believed in it.
And I believed
that eventually I'd
gain a couple more
customers every year,
and I'd create a following.
Sometimes, these
things take time, OK?
And after about
five or six years,
I was the asparagus king.
So I made it to pretzel
king and asparagus king.
And I really started promoting
this white asparagus.
And at first, I
only had Germans,
because Germans knew about it.
So in that, it's a
very short season.
It usually starts
when the weather
gets warmer, April, May.
You have to we're in
Europe, so it's possible
not to get warm until June.
So it also signals the
beginning of summer, you know?
Sidewalk cafe's open.
People are outside.
It's just a great
time, and that's
when that vegetable is at
the height of the season.
It's about seven to eight weeks.
And all the
restaurants in my area
change their menus
to white asparagus.
And, generally, when
you go to a restaurant
and you look at the
menus, it says steak
with beans, swordfish
with broccoli.
But in the asparagus
season, it's
white asparagus with steak,
white asparagus with swordfish,
white asparagus with shrimp.
The white asparagus is the star.
So I believed in this, and
it really took me three years
and then it kind of took off.
And now you're starting
to see it everywhere.
Well, not everywhere.
Per pound, white
asparagus is more
expensive than
lobster, maybe even
twice the price of lobster.
That gives you an
idea of why maybe it
hasn't been as popular yet, and
it's also very hard to find.
OK.
They've tried, and for
awhile I used to get it
from a farm in Indiana.
Here, it needs a
very specific soil.
It's like sandy and
a lot of moisture.
So it's usually grown
alongside rivers or lakes
with very sandy soil.
They haven't been able
to-- you can get some
from South America, but
don't waste your money.
They're no good.
Do it right, like the tomato.
You want to eat a tomato,
you eat a good tomato
or don't eat it at all.
I grew up right
next to the border
of France and Switzerland.
I would walk to France,
and I would take my bike
to Switzerland.
I didn't think of anything doing
that, but it was a great area.
There was great food, because
we had influence from France
and we had influence
from Switzerland.
And it's kind of considered
the Toscana of Germany
because it's the warmest region
of Germany-- so lots of foods,
lots of vegetables, wine.
We have some good
wines in Germany also
that are becoming more
and more popular here now.
OK.
Yes?
Just a string, yeah.
A little twine.
If I had cheesecloth,
I would show it to you.
But it's very simple.
It's like a napkin.
You fold it out.
Put out the napkin.
Put it in the center.
Pull it up.
Tie it and just hang
it in the fridge.
And put a bowl below, obviously.
Because it drips.
That's it.
And you're removing a
lot of the moisture.
That then allows you to add
some of the other-- the yogurt,
the olive oil, the lemon juice,
without it being too runny.
Wow.
So what else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HANS ROECKENWAGNER: We do both.
We obviously have a lot
of different breads.
So we do both.
Make your own starter, yeah.
Rapeseeds, it's actually
relatively easy.
If ever you want a
tour of the bakery,
I'd be happy to give you a tour.
It's great fun, seeing a bakery
in action with 70, 80 bakers.
It's a lot of fun.
We still do a lot
of stuff by hand.
It's called mandrolic.
There are certain machines
that-- like, for instance,
the kneading of the dough.
It's so funny.
What I'm learning more and
more in the baking industry
is that a lot of these machines
that we use in the bakery
are super, super specific.
They do one task
and one task only.
And that task they
try to mimic the hand
as much as possible--
the kneading,
the shaping, the cutting.
All these things,
the machines try
to mimic what the
hand motion does.
So you will have a machine
that literally all it
does is it takes the dough
and it divides it balls.
That's all it does.
But that's a $50,000 machine.
And then the next machine
will shape it like your hand.
Because when you
have a ball of dough,
you're rounding it in your
hand to become a ball.
And as you're doing that,
you're giving it elasticity
and you're giving it a
tension on the surface.
And that's why
very often you see
the one roll is a
little bit bigger,
and the other one
is a little smaller,
and the next one is
a little flatter.
Well, not everyone
has the same hand.
Not everyone has
the same tension.
And not everyone
has the same motion.
In bakery, my big business
now, the biggest thing
that we face on a daily
basis, what is it?
Consistency!
It may sound so
simple, but I have
customers that rely
on that hamburger bun
to be 4 inches, not 5 inches,
not 3 inches-- four inches.
Because if it's 3 inches,
the meat hangs over it.
If it's 5 inches, you
can't see the meat.
So consistency, for us
in the bakery business,
is the biggest deal.
I'm telling you, at
times it's even more
important than quality.
And actually, for
me as a chef, that
was a little bit
of a revelation.
Because as a chef,
you are always
trying for that 100%, 100%.
That's all you do.
You try to achieve
100% everything you do.
But as a baker, you'd
be setting yourself up.
Because you cannot
deliver everyday 100%.
So you have to actually
pare back just a little bit
to be within that tolerance
of what you're making.
Because your customer
accepts quality.
Quality is important.
Don't get me wrong.
I mean, I'm still
driven by quality.
But in the bakery business,
consistency is huge, huge.
I have a lot of
people out there.
Oh, I'll just open my bakery.
OK, great.
Please, go ahead.
And then next thing, they
start out with a great bread.
We have a lot of upcoming
hot bakers out there
that put out a great product.
Five Loaves-- great product.
Now multiply that by--
we make between 35,000,
50,000 pieces every single
day-- every single day.
So that's where the challenge
comes in when you grow
and when you start delivering to
other people from Santa Barbara
to San Diego-- my bike
ride this weekend.
So that's our challenge
in the bakery business.
And I'm really excited about all
these young bakers coming up,
putting out really
good stuff, good stuff.
And that's good
for us, especially
us who are really into quality.
We're really into that
super the ultimate.
And it's great.
I love it.
But then making it times 30,
40, 50,000 is a different story.
We make at the bakery
350 different products
every day fresh.
Nothing is frozen.
Made daily, delivered daily.
I'm really proud of that.
You know what I think?
Now looking back at
my career, you know,
I used to serve 20
people in my first run.
30 people.
Later on, maybe
100 people a day.
Dinner.
If you think about
that, I touch possibly
in the tens of thousands
of people's lives
every single day,
trying my product.
That's awesome.
I go to places.
Sometimes, I'm
invited for dinner.
And they don't know.
And I see my bread on the table.
I'm like, wow.
That's great.
You know?
That's fantastic.
Right?
So I'm having a much bigger
impact with that than I ever
had with my restaurants.
I take nothing away from what
I have done in my restaurants.
I'm super proud of it.
But you know, it's
tough out there.
I see all these
young guys really,
really working very
hard and putting
a lot of good--
they were wearing
their heart of their
sleeves, and they're
putting it out there.
And we are the
benefactors of that.
Yes?
I had one of my friends
place an ad in the paper.
But that doesn't work anymore.
He was one of my
best bakers ever.
He helped set us
up, and he moved on.
He became a baking instructor,
actually, up north.
But we've had a lot of
good bakers and still do.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HANS ROECKENWAGNER: No,
actually lots of people.
But then comes the, well,
what about the visa?
What about this?
What about that?
And I've brought
over a lot of people,
and it didn't work out
after weak, you know?
It's just culture shock,
different circumstances,
different situations.
It's not so easy.
Well, I think that's it.
I've talked myself out.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Come on over.